[Music]
the biggest kidney stone on record
weighed more than a kilogram and was 17
centimeters in diameter the patient
didn't actually swallow a stone the size
of a coconut kidney stones form inside
the body but unfortunately they're
extremely painful to get out a kidney
stone is a hard mass of crystals that
can form in the khitans ureters bladder
or urethra urine contains compounds that
consist of calcium sodium potassium
oxalate uric acid and phosphate if the
levels of these particles get too high
or if urine becomes too acidic or basic
the particles can clump together and
crystallize unless the problem is
addressed the crystals will gradually
grow over a few weeks months or even
years forming a detectable stone calcium
oxalate is the most common type of
crystal to form this way and accounts
for about 80% of kidney stones less
common kidney stones are made of calcium
phosphate or uric acid a slightly
different type of stone made of the
minerals magnesium ammonium phosphate or
struvite can be caused by bacterial
infection and even rarer stones can
result from genetic disorders or certain
medications a kidney stone can go
undetected until it starts to move when
a stone travels through the kidney and
into the ureter its sharp edges scratch
the walls of the urinary tract nerve
endings embedded in this tissue transmit
excruciating pain signals through the
nervous system and the scratches can
send blood flowing into the urine
this can be accompanied by symptoms of
nausea vomiting and a burning sensation
while urinating if a stone gets big
enough to actually block the flow of
urine it can create an infection or
backflow and damage the kidneys
themselves but most kidney stones don't
become this serious or even require
invasive treatment masses less than five
millimeters in diameter will usually
pass out of the body on their own a
doctor will often simply recommend
drinking large amounts of water to help
speed the process along and maybe taking
some painkillers
if the stone is slightly larger
medications like alpha blockers can help
by relaxing the muscles in the ureter
and making it easier for the stone to
get through another medication called
potassium citrate can help dissolve the
stones by creating a less acidic urine
for medium-sized stones up to about ten
millimeters one option is pulverizing
them with soundwaves extracorporeal
shock wave lithotripsy uses
high-intensity pulses of focused
ultrasonic energy aimed directly at the
stone the pulses create vibrations
inside the stone itself and small
bubbles jostle it these combined forces
crush the stone into smaller pieces that
can pass out of the body more easily but
zapping a stone with sound doesn't work
as well if it's simply too big so
sometimes more invasive treatments are
necessary a rigid tube called a stent
can be placed in the ureter to expand it
optical fibres can deliver laser pulses
to break up the stone stones can also be
surgically removed through an incision
in the patient's back or groin what
about just avoiding kidney stones in the
first place for people prone to them
their doctor may recommend drinking
plenty of water which dilutes the
calcium oxalate and other compounds that
eventually build up into painful stones
[Music]
foods like potato chips spinach rhubarb
and beets are high in oxalate so doctors
might advise limiting them even though
calcium is often found in stones calcium
in foods and beverages can actually help
by binding to oxidate in the digestive
tract before it can be absorbed and
reached the kidneys if you do end up
with a kidney stone you're not alone
data suggests that rates are rising but
that world record probably won't be
broken anytime soon
you
[Music]